contre en ce moment à berlin entre le
président français emmanuel macron et le
nouveau chancelier allemand olaf scholz
tous deux devraient tenter d'adopter une
position commune face à moscou on va en
parler avec vous bruno daroux bonjour
bonjour club est les deux hommes
souhaitent donc une position commune
mais le successeur d'angela merkel est à
la tête d'une coalition très divisés sur
ce sujet oui c'est pas c'est pas simple
pour olaf scholz en effet alors on peut
dire quand même qu'à un niveau
diplomatique la france et l'allemagne
sont d'accord sur le fait qu' il faut
préparer des sanctions massives contre
la russie en cas d'invasion de l'ukraine
mais que parallèlement il faut tout
faire pour maintenir le dialogue
là-dessus paris et berlin sont en ligne
d'ailleurs côté français le conseiller
diplomatique à l'elysée sur la russie
pierre vimont est en ce moment même à
moscou pour essayer de mettre au point
un appel entre vladimir poutine et
emmanuel macron donc sur cette double
approche si vous voulez dialogue fermeté
ya pas vraiment de grandes différences
au niveau des principes entre la france
et l'allemagne après là où ça se
complique un peu c'est en fait sur la
position de l'allemagne il ya la
position géographique est le rôle de
l'histoire il ya eu ce qu'on appelait
l'ostpolitik la politique vers l'est qui
a été évidemment très importante en
allemagne qui fait que par exemple
l'allemagne refuse de livrer des armes à
l'ukraine pour que l'ukraine puisse
renforcer son armée ce qui fait
d'ailleurs qu'à kiev l'allemagne et est
quasiment accusé de trahir la cause
ukrainienne donc il y à il ya cette
première divergence et puis de l'autre
divergence concernant même si encore une
fois les deux capitales sont d'accord
sur la mise en place de sanctions
massives en cas d'invasion par la russie
de l'ukraine il ya quand même l'histoire
du gazoduc north stream 2 qui relie la
russie à l'allemagne là c'est plutôt au
sein de la coalition un peu hétéroclite
que dirige olaf scholz à berlin sont des
sociaux démocrates notamment qui
ne sont pas tellement chaud finalement
pour refuser de mettre en service ce
gazoduc qui amène donc du gaz russe vers
l'allemagne refusait de mettre en
service le gazoduc cia donc s'il ya une
pénétration de soldats russes en ukraine
pourquoi parce que les
sociaux-démocrates en fait
historiquement ont porté ce projet c'est
l'ancien chancelier gerhard schröder
social démocrate qui allait porter ce
projet c'est lui qui aujourd'hui à la
tête du conseil d'administration de la
société qui chapeaute ce gazoduc doit y
est que là dessus ça reste compliqué
hier les européens ils ont tenté une
nouvelle fois de faire entendre leur
voix sur ce dossier ukrainien entre les
états unis et la russie oui ils essayent
en fait de sortir du piège collard
attendues essentiellement vladimir
poutine puisque vladmir poutine en fait
ils estiment que les européens sont
divisés entre eux qu'il ne parle pas
d'une seule voix il n'est pas très
content de la manière dont la france et
l'allemagne notamment ont mis en accord
dans le cadre de ce qu'on appelle le
farm le fameux format normandie les
accords de minsk en gros un moscou
reproche à paris et berlin notamment de
ne pas avoir fait pression suffisamment
sur kiev concernant la gestion pour
faire simple du territoire du donbass
donc du coup moscow cherché à écarter
les européens à privilégier aussi pour
des raisons de prestige le dialogue
direct entre moscou et washington et les
européens ont un peu si vous me passez
l'expression un peu ramé pour revenir
dans le jeu les américains également
très vite compris le piège que t'en dit
vladimir poutine c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs qu'ils ont énormément
concerter avec leurs alliés européens
quand tony blinken avant de rencontrer
monsieur lavrov à genève cet écart était
déjà à berlin pour rencontrer ses
homologues pour montrer en fait que le
camp occidental était uni mais les
européens globalement sur le principe
c'est un peu pareil quand on la france l
allemagne qui voulaient parle d'une
seule voix disent qu'ils sont sur la
même ligne que les états unis mais en
même temps il ya en gros deux attitudes
parmi les les européens il ya ceux qui
sont très alarmiste évidemment ceux qui
sont en première ligne les pays baltes
et la pologne parce qu'ils sont en
grande proximité de la russie et aussi
la grande bretagne de boris johnson qui
est très en flèche et puis il ya ceux
qui sont plus réalistes qui disent faut
pas perdre ses nerfs c'est une guerre
des nerfs que nous livre la dîmière
poutine dont par exemple les évacuations
de personnels américains abritent la
dramatiser voilà il faut pas il faut pas
tomber non plus dans ce piège là